the numbers keep going up in northern
mozambique
according to the un's refugee agency
nearly 700
000 people have been forced to flee
their homes and more than 2 000
have been killed when herculano's
village in kisanga came under attack one
night
he fled with his wife children and
grandchildren
i left because of the war that affected
us it was at night
so we fled into the bush we stayed four
days in the bush
looking for a way out and running away
from the conflict
mozambique's government says fighters
affiliated to isil
are operating in parts of cabo delgado
the militant group
staged its first attack in 2017.
since then the attacks have been bigger
in scale and frequency
taking on the army and the times seizing
entire towns
humanitarian workers reports beheadings
rape
abductions and other human rights abuses
i spoke to a grandmother who
whose daughter was killed during the
conflict
and the father of the child was beheaded
and the grandmother
is now caring for that child
another woman i met is caring for
a stranger's child who is now orphaned
so this is common
in this community now where the women
are caring for each other's
children where the parents have been
lost
the government has started moving people
to resettlement sites
where it's believed to be safer but
conditions there are basic
and more funding and planning is needed
to cover food
medicines and other necessities the
covert 19 pandemic
has made an already die economic and
humanitarian crisis
worse a lot of resources are needed
we do not expect looking at the
situation we do not expect
the amount of people the number of
people being displaced to
the flow to stop unfortunately for the
time being and therefore
more assistance is needed the un is
warning poverty
frustration and unemployment in this
gas-rich region
is making it easy for armed groups to
recruit
the united states says its special
forces will help
train soldiers in mozambique to fight
the insurgents
portugal the country's former colonial
power has also committed to training the
military
for now people waiting for help to
arrive say they feel abandoned
by their country and the international
community haru mutasa
al jazeera